in 2006 I want a national competition to
spend two weeks at NASA's Kennedy and
Johnson Space Center's I saw the Space
Shuttle land
I met astronauts I did astronaut
training one of the BBC reports I
featured in described it as a
once-in-a-lifetime trip and I hated that
but first let's backtrack one day a few
people in my year 10 shooter group
discovered this competition called edge
into space we had to design something
which is gonna improve life in space in
some way like me they were massive dorks
love you guys and so we formed a team
our idea was to create a temporary
pressurized oxygenated environment that
you could use in space exploration base
it was a tent but basically we designed
a space 10 that you could use on the
moon and you could extend your range of
operations away from like a lander and
so we've made a presentation that
explained what the idea was how you
would use it and some of the science
involved like using electrolysis of
water to create oxygen and we sent it
off 2006 me year 10 me was very
different to the version of me that you
see on youtube today
there wasn't a single thing in my
academic track record that was notable
in any way I was just a kid in a normal
school in the West Country of England
but after this trip everything changed
because somehow we were selected as the
winners of the competition from the
southwest of England and so we were
taken on this two-week trip along with
the winners from other parts of the UK
to NASA now the two weeks we went to
NASA were officially designated as the
work experience weeks we hear 10
students in the UK so those are the
weeks when you go and you work in a
company that's relevant to your career
interests and you get same spot on your
CV but we didn't do that because we went
to NASA but considering at the time I
wanted to be an astronaut and I still do
now who doesn't and that whilst we were
there we learned all about the space
industry from the inside and did
astronaut training in a way I kind of
did to work experience at NASA however
if you click this video expecting a
detailed breakdown of how you two can
successfully apply 2d work experience at
NASA then you might be all like
Master Kenobi you disappoint me but
should you click off this video oh I
don't think so incidentally am I going
to be using prequel memes in my videos
from now on I mean something Goods got
to come out of how terrible Attack of
the Clones was the trip was a
once-in-a-lifetime event
in that you can't go on it it only ever
happened once but in this video I want
to talk about what happened on the trip
how it changed my life and eventually
why the phrase once-in-a-lifetime trip
is the verbal version of Attack of the
Clones firstly before even getting to
Florida one of the scariest events of my
entire life happened on this trip when I
was pulled aside at Newark Airport so
this is in New York because I flew from
London to New York New York to Florida I
will put aside I think because I've got
some paperwork wrong and taken into this
small room with a massively tall desk
and a border official with a gun and
asked what what you're doing in New York
and I said I was getting a connecting
flight in Florida and then no joke his
response to me was to look me dead in
the eye and say okay why are you
pretending to do that what do you say
what do you say to that I'm going to
NASA to be an astronaut I'm going to
space count actually I think I did
literally say both those things there
let me go in the end for whatever reason
in Florida we spent several days at the
Kennedy Space Center so this is the
Space Center where Rockets are launched
into space and we did a historical tour
of sites like the Apollo 1 launch
memorial we saw two of the unused Saturn
5 rockets which are impossibly big and
we also went into the block houses which
were the protective buildings that were
used in the very early days of NASA we
also did a workshop building paper
rockets and this was mine visited the
planetarium and went to SeaWorld where I
did not enjoy the rides each day was
completely different but basically we
got super up close to the nuts and bolts
of the space industry this was a million
miles away from anything we'd
experienced before we were seeing the
culmination of decades of technical and
scientific expertise in the flesh this
was
tens of thousands of hours of effort and
preparation and payoff but I didn't come
away from looking at this thinking oh
wow isn't that amazing that people have
done that or even I want to do this I
want to do this as well like I think the
message I got was simply this is
possible yeah
I love space and spaceflight then as I
do now but seeing literally the history
of rocketry evolving in front of me
didn't make me want to recreate it it
made me want to build my own things and
of all the things that we did in Florida
nothing conveyed that more than seeing
the space shuttle land from the VIP area
it was shuttle flight sts-121 if you
must know I can promise you that it is
one thing to read about space hardware
and entirely another to see it in action
right in front of you I mean seeing what
what is basically the most iconic
spacecraft ever land right in front of
you and nearly supersonic speeds and
it's blackened and charred from going
through the atmosphere that's possibly
the coolest thing I've ever seen in my
life I think I said as much at the time
actually
[Music]
[Applause]
you leave us just been out in space no
just looks like a plane is just landed
all the same it's raw star just saw it
it was going so quickly it's like a dot
on the horizon and suddenly is there and
it was all you can see it was child from
going through the atmosphere and I think
that's because I was clearly such a
natural on camera when we next flew to
Houston in Texas to do some astronaut
training at the Johnson Space Center
including a simulated spacewalk and a
simulated lunar walk with lunar gravity
I was put in front of the camera again
this time it was after I've been on the
multi-axis generator so I've been spun
in loads of different directions all at
once came to a halt and then whoop
camera right in front my face if they
tumbled out of control in orbit
you could realign yourself and I can't
pay for the experience and that was
weird your head still swimming the blood
rushes the air and then it goes down the
other half of your body and then you put
your stomach's at the centrist he didn't
get in or check you try and do a
coherent interview after being spun in a
million different directions much as the
astronaut training day was fun I think
the thing which changed my life happened
at the very end of the trip because in
Houston we saw the training facilities
for astronauts we saw the neutral
buoyancy lab we saw the actual space
shuttle used to Train astronauts we saw
the Mission Control for the
International Space Station
I'm tween that software and that
preparation and the hardware in Kennedy
there's the component without which the
whole thing would be pointless on our
last night in America we met the
astronaut twins Scott and Mark Kelly the
latter of which had just piloted the
space shuttle back to earth
two days before and he wasn't scheduled
to meet us he just knew that his brother
was gonna be there meeting some kids and
decided to turn up saying that I just I
just would've been on the safer
otherwise service in space the tumors in
space two days before these guys were to
me then and still now living legends
they were the culmination the neck
of decades of scientific and technical
and engineering expertise of hundreds of
thousands of hours of training and
preparation and studying they were what
was possible they represented what I now
saw I could be so when I went back home
to England as I said earlier everything
changed like a line in the sand before
the NASA trip
nothing academically exceptional about
me at all after the trip best GCSEs in
my school went to Oxford to study
physics got my PhD a phrase that I
really like is that we are all prisoners
of our previous reference point it's
difficult to seriously dream big when
you are limited to a small part of your
country where frankly nothing happens
going to NASA open my eyes to what was
possible if you are willing to train and
put the time in and do practice problem
after problem after problem after
problem until you can do something
flawlessly it prepares to the point
where you can do something perfectly
every time
like Marc and Scott Kelly did in space
edge into space redefined what I thought
was possible with my life which brings
me on to the phrase once-in-a-lifetime
trip it implies that once something
amazing has happened
you should contend yourself by just
saying well I'm glad that happened and
then going on living the rest of your
life how pathetic is that yes there are
events which can only ever happen once
in a lifetime like seeing Halley's Comet
or watching a particular star goes
supernova and yes trying to recreate
exceptional events can literally drive a
person insane but why should you ever be
content to have your life your one
chance at life to ever be limited
every time I've experienced something
wants in a lifetime and I've been lucky
enough to experience
quite a few I've not come away satisfied
I wanted more and I've used the event to
springboard me to further success I used
it to redefine the reference point that
I'm prisoner to in the case of going to
NASA I came home and I got serious about
studying I'd seen what was possible if I
dedicated time to the grind
to preparing for my exams to studying
and so I adjusted how I was living my
life to realize what I saw as my new
potential that potential had always been
there I hadn't fundamentally changed as
a person but I didn't see the heights
that I could reach and so my new
reference point had removed the
limitations that I'd subconsciously put
on my own future because that's the only
way to respond to being told that you're
doing something once-in-a-lifetime by
changing that lifetime to prove the
speaker wrong by changing how you live
your life to make what was once
exceptional your new normal as long as
this is for positive experiences we
don't want attack of the clones to
become the new normal quality for Star
Wars pip oh no after my trip to NASA
something that I very specifically did
was up my game in terms of past papers
and doing practice questions for my
GCSEs doing problem after problem after
problem after problem until I thoroughly
understood the concepts on the mats and
science syllabi I think you work pretty
well and if you'd like to follow the
same path and learn as I did drilling
problem after problem in maths and
science there's no better place to do
that than brilliant org in particular if
you are interested in spaceflight you
are definitely gonna want to check out
their course on classical mechanics
which as its tagline suggests is
hardcore training for the aspiring
physicist
makes you better at maths and science
using exactly the same technique that
used drilling through practice problems
identifying your misconceptions when you
get something wrong and then iterating
until you've rigorously understand the
concepts it worked for me and if you
want it to work for you to go to
brilliant org forward slash Simon Clark
and the first 200 people to go to that
link will also get 20% off their annual
premium subscription I hope you enjoyed
this video do pop it alike if you did if
you're not already subscribe to the
channel and thank you for watching I'll
see you next time
[Music]